-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show"!
We are hanging out
with Steve Martin
and Martin Short, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are about to --
-Let's see how you do
in that spot.
[ Laughter ]
-We're about to play a game...
-Oh, boy.
-...called "Hey Robot."
Here we go.
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, robot ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
-Now here's how it works.
Okay?
This is based on a real
board game called "Hey Robot."
You can play at home.
It's like the classic game
"Password," okay?
But your partner
is a smart speaker, okay?
So, first, I will pick a card --
-So, it's not Marty.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
You don't have to make him
guess things, no.
But I will pick a card
with a word on it,
and then we'll take turns
asking a question to the speaker
to get it to say that word
somewhere in its answer, okay?
-And we all have the same word?
-No.
Well, maybe. It depends if we --
-Can you go back
over the rules again?
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go.
Let me try it.
I'll -- All right.
Here's the word
I have to get this thing to say.
-Mm-hmm.
-Uh-huh.
-Okay.
Mistletoe.
I can say it.
All right, here we go.
Hey, Alexa,
what do you kiss someone under
during the holiday season?
-From wikipedia.org,
it is a Christmas custom
for a couple
who meet under a mistletoe
to kiss.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what we're doing.
So that's
what we're talking about.
That's the idea.
-I'm there.
I get it.
-You got it, okay, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Marty --
Marty, you're up.
Would you like to go first?
-Okay, sure.
-You should probably take this.
-No, it's fine.
-Here's your word.
-Okay.
-All right.
You have to say, "Hey..."
-I'm not an idiot.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Alexa -- don't you have
to hit the button?
Oh. Oh!
I'm sorry.
-So you kind of are an idiot?
[ Laughter ]
-Let's see -- Let's see --
Let's see what Alexa says.
[ Laughter ]
-Hold on.
-Start again.
-Hey, Alexa, what is that name
of the paper stuff
you put on Christmas trees
that's all sparkly?
-From homecrux.com,
to add sparkle and glimmer
to your Christmas tree,
carve out the eye-catching
cardboard star ornaments.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-And, by the way,
it's not made of paper.
You know that?
-What's it made of?
-It's made of, like,
foil, aluminum.
-Yeah.
-No, it isn't.
-Oh, you're from Canada.
What do you know?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no, no, no.
-All right, Steve,
it's your turn.
Let's --
-So I'm losing this stupid game?
[ Laughter ]
-No, you're losing
more than that.
[ Laughter ]
You're losing fans, buddy.
-Oh, my --
[ Laughter ]
-All right, here you go.
-I told you this chair
was better.
-I've g-- oh, Jesus.
-Okay.
-What was it? Let's see.
-Okay, let's hear that.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Alexa, what is roasting
on an open fire?
-You bastards.
[ Laughter ]
-According to
an Alexa Answers contributor,
roasting is a cooking method
that uses dry heat...
[ Laughter ]
...where hot air covers
the food, cooking it evenly
on all sides
with temperatures of at least
150 degrees Celsius --
300 degrees Fahrenheit --
from an open flame...
-You got a pen?
[ Laughter ]
-...or other heat source.
-Hey, let me do --
-Shh!
-Roasting can enhance the flavor
through caramelization
and maillard browning
on the surface.
-I've got a flight Sunday.
-Let me try to do --
Let me try -- Let's try --
-You think you can do it?
-I want to try it, too.
-You want to try it, too?
All right.
I'm gonna say, um...
Uh, uh...
Chestnuts. Okay.
Chestnuts.
Uh...
Gosh.
I don't know if I can -- okay.
Alexa, what do you roast
during the holiday season, nut?
[ Laughter ]
-That's cheating!
-From recipes.com,
traditional holiday cuts include
the standing rib roast,
prime rib, rack of pork,
and beef tenderloin.
-I have one.
-I have it.
Alexa, what was Steve Martin's
nickname in high school?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no, I got one.
I got one.
Hey -- Wait a minute.
Hey, Alexa.
What is the first line
of Mel Torme's song
"The Christmas Song"?
-From the piano.sg, Mel Torme's
"The Christmas Song"
is etched indelibly in our minds
with its famous opening lyrics,
"Chestnuts roasting
on an open fire."
[ Ding! ]
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-O-h-h-h-h-h-h!
-Wow!
That's amazing.
-Come on, that's it.
Steve Martin, there he is.
Great career.
Steve Martin, Martin Short.
That's what I'm talking about!
1,000 points!
They're hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend, with musical guest
Brandi Carlile!
We'll be right back with H.E.R.!
Come on back!
Wow!